let's talk about arch enemy you play
this i this is my favorite
character name uh a great character but
also great character name
max fist
yes yes take it easy this is a show
primarily for children so let's tone it
down
i didn't dip it in the vat of crisco
[Laughter]
so i was trying to keep it clean i was
just giving you
that this is an independent film and
there's intense action
that's got to be difficult i would think
it adds to the adrenaline when you're
shooting these action scenes and it has
to be that precise and you've got to get
it right
and there's no oh don't worry the
computers will clean this up later on
you know yeah there's no computer to
clean it up later on that's it i
i have to get it practically but i i
really love that kind of tightrope
walking and
and i actually enjoy it i like those
steaks all right
let's take a look at this moment from
arch enemy
there's a fragment of the cosmic blood
in this it's a synthetic analog but
but a scent a memory a molecule
oh
i was giving power power to experience
the universe for everyone
all of the timelines all at once all
coursing through my mind so that i could
save them all
are you saying that the cosmic blood is
methamphetamine maybe i haven't tried
hard enough
it allows me to go through what i pull
through the molecules do you understand
me
let's break it through the molecules
and we're back okay for people that
don't know
my character max fist has delusions
he he thinks he's from another dimension
and in this dimension
he was something equivalent to like a
superman or the superhero
right but as you can see from the clip
uh he might just be having a psychotic
episode
from matthews uh he's a homeless man who
is addicted to meth
and alcohol and lives in a tent uh and
has these delusions of being from a
different dimension
um but yes that is uh that's that's him
having a
a psychotic episode or a breakdown uh on
his way to
uh go on an attempted murder spree so i
think there's a lot to unpack there
i had a meth coach on set with me
to to show me how to do meth you could
have just gone method
and been on meth i could i could have
that's where math comes from method
actors yeah math actors are really
pretty much on meth so
you know it's basically uh the plot to
mary poppins
you know that's the the they they remade
it it's quite different than the
spoonful of sugar uh there's a double
meaning there yeah exactly